le mal dominant affirme sa supériorité
par une démonstration de force et
d'agressivité
la petite phrase de Vincent Cassel qui
estime que si les hommes devenaient trop
vulnérables et trop féminin et bien il y
aurait un problème c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré dans le quotidien britannique
The Guardian est-ce qu'on s'en fout ou
pas
joëlie intersidérale donc Charles
en fait de ça enfin je vois pas quel est
le problème dans ce qu'il a dit j'ai pas
envie que tous les hommes deviennent des
femmes il a atteint le statut social le
plus élevé du groupe et détient
désormais de nombreux privilèges comme
celui de s'accoupler avec toutes les
femelles du clan est-ce que je prononce
bien fiou Piou Piou vous avez pas le
prénom le plus facile
un peu Huguen non non on garde Hugues
[Rires]
si elle prend la même couleur que lui le
tour est joué
mais ce ne sera pas pour cette fois le
message est clair
[Musique]
ridicule les gens s'habillent comme ils
veulent si des hommes ont envie de
s'épiler il s'épile si des femmes n'ont
pas envie de s'épiler elle ne s'épile
pas on s'en claque Charles le problème
c'est quand les femmes commencent à
ressembler à des hommes
polémique mise à part on en a dans les
GG je dirais pas qui non je plaisante
que des que des bombes dans les GG
Godefroy les trois fois
et ça je suis quasiment sûr qu'elle va
choquer là c'est pas mal là haut il y a
un petit bourrelet
dans l'ensemble c'est très bien pour la
première fois Cynthia mes bandes elles
sont plus belles que les tiennes je les
ai mieux réussi et c'est Laurent qui me
l'a dit non c'est moi qui monte
[Musique]
c'est pas d'une intelligence foudroyante
mais
en même temps je le rejoins un peu dans
sa beau-fils c'est à dire que quand je
vois les nouvelles générations des gens
wakisés où on a pu le droit de dire tu
es s'ils sont un garçon une fille où il
faut des toilettes neutres
où il se change de sexe à 12 ans et demi
il se tanasie à 13 si tu veux ça
m'inquiète un peu ça rentre pas non
alors
arrêtez Olivier je vous dis que ça ne
rentre pas depuis tout à l'heure
que vous êtes en train de me dire là
c'est bon qu'on se connaît les grands
ravi d'avoir fait votre connaissance
[Rires]
j'ai eu peur que le YouTube n'arrive
jamais
[Rires]
quelle est la ville la plus moche de
France lauréate du prix de la campagne
publicitaire en 2022 c'est la ville de
Moussac dans le Gard avec son avenue des
loisirs le communiqué de l'association
de la France moche qui défend la
visibilité les paysages français ironise
sur cet avenue qui porte bien son nom un
porte vraiment ce nom de l'avenir de la
loisirs la lecture de tous ces panneaux
permet aux automobilistes de ne pas
s'endormir au volant
[Musique]
et puis dernier élu de ce classement de
la France moche 2022 Villard-de-Lans la
station de ski et remercier pour cette
indispensable panneau numérique un grand
cas par 3 qui nous informe qu'il est
16h35 et qui nous montre également en
numérique l'image du paysage de montagne
qu'on pourrait voir derrière le panneau
c'est inexistait pas c'était hier à
Dunkerque vous allez adorer c'est le
point d'orgue de la saison du carnaval
la sortie de la bande des pêcheurs et
son jet de hareng depuis le balcon de
l'hôtel de ville alors regardez il y a
une foule immense ici qui a bataillé
comme chaque année pour récupérer l'un
de ses harengs alors voilà des haricots
qui pour beaucoup
[Rires]
vous voyez mais beaucoup sont emballés
alors voyez enfin c'est bien on a des
images mais on n'a pas l'odeur le
carnaval de Dunkerque c'est aussi le
rendez-vous des mélomanes tous les ans
vous inventez vous écrivez de nouvelles
chansons moi ma préférée c'est quand
même Chantal on dira par la suite
[Musique]
[Rires]
sérieux qui rime avec Chantal on va
mener l'enquête le Championnat du Monde
du cri de la mouette ça donne ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est très bien fait le cri du gagnant
Captain Mamou habillé de plumes pour
l'occasion c'est très réussi donc entre
rigueur et sarcastique que je trouve que
le ton est très bon
certainement deviennent de loin comme
archi-baletta
[Applaudissements]
il a volé traverser la France depuis le
Pays basque pour se confronter au plus
grand alors la moi du Pays Basque en
fait ressemble plus à un goût et là
de la nuance qui a peut-être Momo on
avait à revendre
c'est Lucien 18 ans qui est le gagnant
un jeune de l'Avesnois qui ne savait
même pas il y a un an imitait secret de
la mouette franchement c'est la première
fois que j'ai ici et quel bonheur quel
bonheur je suis je suis arrivé ce matin
je me suis habillé j'ai préparé ça en
deux jours quelle ascension franchement
Captain Moumou la mouette nordiste la
mouette novice il entre avec honneur au
panthéon des mouettes il a rejoint les
étoiles qui l'ont en fait rêver les
jimatsumoto le créateur japonais
d'Albator est décédé star mondial du
manga et de l'animé il est surtout connu
pour ses œuvres de science-fiction dans
l'espace au premier rang desquels le
célèbre capitaine Albator qui a fait
rêver des millions de petits français au
début des années 80 puis on a également
appris la disparition du Sénas français
Michel de ville à 91 ans on lui doit
notamment Benjamin ou les mémoires d'un
puceau avec Michel Morgan Michel Piccoli
Catherine Deneuve il avait remporté deux
César avec péril en la demeure et le
dossier 51